Robbie posher was just 10 feet away from
the suicide bomber when he set off his
explosives he's with us now hi Robbie um
how are you
good morning all okay
I am okay I wondered how you were
feeling about the report being published
later on today bringing back lots of
memories for you
unfortunately yes you will do yes
perhaps you can tell me about what
happened to you on the night
unfortunately um I received lots of two
shoulders one through me heart my lungs
uh and both kneecaps and ultimate
multiple all injuries
talk to me about
um I think you were just what 10 feet or
so away were you from the bomber
are you close yes yeah what did you
notice about him at the time
um he also had quite a big backpack on
but look like someone was looking for
students but Looking Back Now obviously
look very nervous
yeah and then you
yield yourself in a position where you
were severely injured how long did it
take for people to come and help you
um
I believe we have over half an hour
I was lucky because the business
corporate with Brilliance they'd send me
over tried to stop the blood username so
many AC shapes and there's budget he
could
what do you hope that the report finds
later on today
more the truthful
in in that political the security where
in the the build up to it but not taken
away from the fact that the people did
this so the ones we've really got to
concentrate on
yeah do you feel that during the course
of the inquiry that your voice and the
voice of others that was injured that
were injured has been heard by those
that are writing the report
uh now we've also saw our statements in
we've had no contact for
no I honestly yeah yeah I understand
that and how's life been like since
just a long replay building
uh obviously can't let them beat you so
I mean I'm still obviously having secret
now
but you know I'm back up on my face I
can't play rugby again
which is a big killer but yeah
you know there's a lot of people a lot
worse or very a lot worse than what
happened to me so we have to be thankful
for that
so what does a normal life look like for
you now what would you do on a normal
day
a lot earlier to do a lot of stretching
move obviously take a lot of tablets and
proteins for a rattle a bit
um but I said I can't look back because
I am very very lucky to hear because
that's somewhere for what the surgeon
did in the NHS but also the most
ambitious people will actually saved me
on that day
and have you managed to keep in touch
with any of the people that were also
caught up in this time yeah we have a
few different groups it's not like
whatever and we seem to get in touch
mainly around Christmas and obviously
around the anniversary people so they're
just trying to move on so how things are
pops the back of your mind
and where will you be later on to find
out uh what the report has suggested
uh to be honest you are probably gonna
take the dog for a walk
and I'll wait to get all the information
through certain way so I'm a few reports
like yourselves have been very good on
updates and put into language so we can
actually understand
yeah I know it's going to be a tough day
for you robisto um thanks for taking the
time to join us this morning enjoy the
walk with the dog and just take it easy
today thank you well thank you very
welcome thank you very much